[Music]
this is a video about evolution
not the biological evolution you're
familiar with where living organisms
adapt to their environment no this is
about virtual Evolution about
discovering the extent to which video
games and other simulations can shatter
the natural order and let us experiment
with the building blocks of life itself
the ambitious dream of using computers
to simulate life is an old one and you
might be amazed at just how far the
technology has come so for this entry
into the archive we'll take Natural
Selection into our own hands and see
just how far we can push this concept
before things get out of control
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Our Story begins in 1970 when British
mathematician John H Conway unveiled a
game simply called life
the rules are simple within a blank void
you can create tiny pixels called cells
which will reproduce if there are enough
cells next to them but die out if they
get overcrowded or end up alone simple
right will you activate the simulation
and then
foreign
using these rules in basic starting
patterns Conway's Game of Life can
create unbelievably complex chain
reactions that legitimately feel well
alive pretty quickly people discovered
that depending on your initial pattern
specific species would emerge with their
own unique Behavior microbe like
colonies of pixels that appeared to move
were nicknamed spaceships so-called
puffer trains traveled along and left
behind a trail of debris rakes Left
Behind Trails of fully functional
spaceships this pattern called the
rabbit starts small but expands for a
ridiculous amount of in-game time before
stabilizing it's a lot like watching
cells under a microscope of course the
pixels in The Game of Life aren't
actually Alive by most definitions but
they're an incredible starting point
that show just how effective Simple
Rules can be at creating emergent
behaviors it's proven to be a game with
almost Limitless potential foreign
but we can take things further life
engine is a more recent game by the
amazing YouTuber emergent Garden that
simulates not just emergent Behavior but
natural selection like Conway's Game
life engine is all about pixels but here
different colored pixels have different
functions orange pixels act as a mouth
allowing life forms to consume energy
green pixels produce energy like plants
blue pixels can move about like animals
pink pixels do damage to other life
forms and purple pixels act like armor
against damage finally gray pixels act
as eyes allowing the smartest virtual
life forms to avoid each other
when you begin a game in life engine it
always starts with a massive stationary
life forms slowly expanding out from the
center via reproduction yet each time a
pixel reproduces it has a random chance
of changing color simulating a genetic
mutation as with real world natural
selection some of the mutations like
movement prove advantageous and give
that specific life form more
opportunities to reproduce in almost
every game fast moving life forms
quickly overwhelm the stationary
plant-like creatures and then settle
into an equilibrium much like on Earth
from here this simulated petri dish
becomes a Battleground with different
species evolving weapons armor and
evasive maneuvers to out-compete each
other
a similar YouTuber created game is the
bibbets a simulator where endearing
virtual creatures compete for food this
game also works on a system of random
mutation in natural selection with the
titular bibbets getting more and more
complicated the more you play there's
more to both games than this and there's
a link to them and all the other games
and experiments discussed in this video
in the description
there are a lot of incredible games in
this category of cell-like evolution
simulators like the highly underrated
cute mold by eritau which lets you
simulate the growth of different slime
molds or the remarkable clusters by
algorithmic artist Jeffrey ventrella
that renders a Micro World of particle
systems that begin to display
increasingly complex behaviors not due
to some hidden AI but purely as the
result of a system based on the laws of
physics many of these games are inspired
by Conway's life in some capacity but
all have their own unique spin
there's one final computational model
that demands attention developed by
scholar Bert Chan in 2015 lenia is an
award-winning program derived from
Conway's Game of Life that uses
continuous generalization to make
everything smooth and ethereal using
high resolution patterns Linea produces
far more complicated types of Digital
Life with over 400 individual species
discovered Linea patterns have displayed
an impressive number of the traits we
typically associate with biological life
including bilaterally and radially
symmetrical body plans reproduction and
even intercommunication between colonies
China's even organize these patterns
into a taxonomic tree of evolution some
of which are so Advanced some have
called them mathematical life forms and
sure by most definitions these patterns
aren't truly alive they're just the
result of rules interacting in unique
ways but in a way our universe and all
the Incredibles systems of life within
it are also the result of rules
interacting in unique ways and these
simulations are only getting more
advanced
following the path of life on Earth it's
time to leave the virtual tide pool of
cell simulators and take our first very
awkward steps onto dry land evolution is
a game by programmer K1 that allows you
to build digital Animals by connecting
joints with bones and bones with AI
controlled muscle tendons the game's
neural network will then try its
absolute best to get the creature to
walk forwards over multiple generations
with each attempt appearing as a little
ghost next to the current model at first
most simulations are an absolute mess of
failed attempts but with enough
Generations the neural network will
eventually get better at moving even if
it's not in the way you expect and
that's because this AI doesn't know what
walking looks like which is why at first
it's quite bad at it every movement it
learns is through trial and error
essentially running off its own version
of natural selection and with enough
practice these simulated creatures can
evolve movement patterns that are
reasonable close to the real thing and
it's not just walking that this network
is capable of depending on the design of
your creature it might learn to roll or
hop around like a kangaroo or even take
to the skies and there are more
challenging tasks available than walking
in a straight line you can try to make
the poor creature climb an infinite
staircase or jump over fast-moving
obstacles while at times hilarious there
is a strange tragedy in watching these
innocent creatures struggle Against
Gravity something about this game really
captures the unfeeling nature of natural
selection where advancement often
involves countless generations of
failure though cleverly simplified this
is in many ways the story of life on
Earth
a similar game to evolution is Evo pedal
a walking simulator created by Evol
games where a life form made up of
randomly mutating blocks learns to
travel forwards the game also has an
amazing 3D version where a CGI model of
a human will learn to walk by any means
necessary which can have both amusing
and unsettling results with over 100
moving Parts it's difficult for the AI
to stay coordinated you can also adjust
the settings to allow for non-human
movements like knees that bend backwards
which often leads to even more uncanny
sites the game even lets you fully
adjust the gravity and pushing the
setting too far can lead to things
breaking down a bit such is the price of
Glorious glorious evolution
but maybe we're taking too many steps
too quickly after all life on our planet
didn't first evolve to move on land but
in the much more forgiving environment
of water
in 2016 a group of scientists used
artificial Evolution to successfully
produce swimming soft-bodied creatures
these simulated life forms were made of
squares of virtual tissue with green
representing actively moving tissue and
blue representing passive tissues the AI
found that using a combination of both
resulted in the most efficient swimming
methods producing a range of body types
convergent with various forms of life in
our own oceans and to study the
relationship between swimming and
walking some of these creatures were
moved onto land where they found clever
ways to use bodies of old for aquatic
motion to navigate a terrestrial setting
that same year another group of
scientists ran a similar soft-bodied
creature experiment where a network
evolved a body from a single initial
cell each evolutionary run produced
something different but many looked
remarkably close to biological life it's
worth remembering that this AI didn't
know what a leg or a tail is it just
found a way to keep balance that is
convergent with life on Earth
on the subject of muscle-based
locomotion one of the most well-known
experiments comes from 2013 with a 3D
simulation of various bipedal creatures
these models learn to walk through trial
and error over multiple Generations no
motion capture or keyframe animation was
used with the impressive final results
the product of AI learning the examiners
then pitted this AI against different
Target speeds which led to the creatures
adjusting their gate accordingly they
even put them through obstacle courses
throwing virtual boxes at them and
adding random slopes to their
environments while sometimes they'd
succeed in catching the AI off guard the
overall results were strikingly
consistent
a more recent experiment presented at
the iclr conference used an analogous
method to teach different models to walk
many of these results resemble a
three-dimensional version of one of the
evolution video games as both are
attempting to simulate similar things
but these scientific simulations are not
games as we understand them although
this technology May one day be used to
make virtual entertainment more lifelike
as amazing as all these simulations and
video games are for me there's always
been that faint dream of the one unified
game that combines cellular models with
Aquatic and terrestrial Locomotion to
create the ultimate evolution simulating
Masterpiece for a lot of people that
dream once had a name and its name was
Spore released in the late 2000s the
build-up to Spore was to put it mildly
completely nuts as early as 2005 demos
of this hyper detailed procedurally
generated Universe simulator were being
shown and it looked incredible there was
a sense among some before its release
that this game which seemed to merge
science with infinite customization
would change the industry forever
and then the game came out
while Spore did impress with its
creativity and ambition a lot of people
felt the game was significantly
shallower and less uh scientific than
they were led to believe before to be
clear I'm still quite a fan of this game
despite its eccentricities just looking
at it gives me a huge hit of nostalgia
and it does explore a number of the
principles of evolution in biology and
its own unique manner but it certainly
takes a more cartoonish approach to the
stages of life and some features
advertised like an underwater
multicellular stage weren't in the final
game for many it wasn't the
comprehensive Evolution simulator they
were hoping for
yet the dream of Spore hasn't vanished
just yet recently there has been a surge
of new games that seem to take some of
the concepts of Spore and push them
further one game on this exciting New
Frontier is adapt by Paul irvay
currently a work in progress adapt is a
game that lets you build your own life
form much like spore's creature stage
although it has a greater emphasis on
biological plausibility and finding your
Niche through careful evolutionary
choices and unlike Spore adapt lets you
build creatures specifically adapted for
a semi-aquatic lifestyle the game is
currently free to play on Steam and is a
promising addition to this emerging
sub-genre
one Evolution simulator that really
impresses with its sheer amount of
detail is the sapling created by Wessel
stoop this polygon art sandbox game lets
you design every organism in an
ecosystem and then simulate their
interactions over multiple generations
and I do mean every organism unlike most
games in this genre you're not just
designing animals but plants too and
even things like algae in the depths of
these systems are absolutely
mind-blowing when placing a plant you
need to consider how many leaves it has
relative to the sunlight and the length
of its roots and the amount of
groundwater in the area and the soil
softness and the temperature and the
wind strength different plant colors
realistically grow Better or Worse
depending on the type of star your
planet orbits there's a full system of
flowers you can add to plants that
produce different amounts of pollen that
affects reproductivity you can use
bioluminescence in plants to attract
pollinators were used by luminescence in
animals to mislead prey in terms of
creatures there are flying life forms
detailed customization options for
aquatic life and different eyes that can
see different ranges of infrared and
ultraviolet light you can even adjust
the instincts of each animal using a
modular system of commands to change how
they react to different creatures sound
frequencies in specific colors it's
absolutely off the chain especially when
you consider that like adapt the sapling
was developed by just one person
compared to Spore which was made by a
Goliath of a team these single developer
games of course don't have the same
resources behind them but the incredible
results show that there are still
passionate people who believe in this
idea this dream of a game that could
simulate life like never before
and if we're going to talk about
dreamers we have to talk about thrive
beginning development over a decade ago
Thrive is a game quite unambiguously
born out of frustration with the final
product of Spore a communal project open
to all who wish to contribute the game
takes a far more ambitious and
scientific approach to spores gameplay
Loop in the game you start as a single
realistic cell in a tide pool as you
advance your cell splits into a complex
multicellular organism becoming a 3D
model that can be fully shaped by the
player with different organs serving
unique functions over the next few
stages this creature grows in size and
intelligence eventually able to
communicate using a multi-faceted
language system and create technology
until eventually the technology
compounds to the point where you ascend
to a Godlike level of power and can
control the entire galaxy it's all so
cool
it also doesn't exist
since Thrive is a crowdsource game
anyone on the internet can come up with
ideas for Thrive but actually
implementing those ideas is another
story most of the images people share of
the game's later stages is actually art
by The Talented psycho cot right now
over a decade after the game's Inception
the only playable stage is the first one
the microbe stage and to be clear this
initial stage is very interesting it's
an exceedingly complex and realistic
cell simulator where instead of eating
cartoon plants you're balancing your
glucose ammonia and phosphate levels in
many ways making it a game about virtual
chemistry while this attention to
Scientific detail makes the game fairly
difficult it's a truly admirable product
another cool thing about Thrive is that
while you build and design your cell
other cells in the environment randomly
mutate and adapt with any given game
creating hundreds of interconnected
microbe lineages all with their own
randomly generated scientific name
most people seem to be aware that the
other stages of Thrive aren't coming for
a while but it is pretty inspiring to
see so many people drawn in by this idea
and shows that the dream of the ultimate
evolution simulator hasn't gone extinct
just yet
before this journey through virtual
Evolution concludes there's one last
thing I have to show you a simulation
that does something incredible not by
thinking big but by thinking small
really small open worm is an
international open science project with
the sole purpose of simulating every
cell of a type of worm that grows just
under one millimeter in length that
includes every neuron in its body the
wiring that connects these neurons
muscle cells organs and even its genetic
code the current model is so complete
that when placed into an environmental
simulation it can move like a worm as
incredible as this Recreation is however
it is still not a perfect match with
replicating the electrical signals
within the brain a future hurdle but it
may only be a matter of time
as our ability to simulate life gets
more and more accurate I can't help but
wonder about our responsibilities over
the course of making this video I cause
thousands of virtual life forms to
expire for the purpose of education and
entertainment and sure these creatures
were pixels just ones and zeros but
looking at how our ability to simulate
Evolution has evolved it's clear that
things are advancing rapidly if one day
we are able to truly render a universe
in a box filled with virtual creatures
indistinguishable from biological life I
wonder if we'll have to start having
more serious conversations about what we
do with that power we all know how
people play The Sims after all
perhaps one day we'll think of those
first pixels placed in Conway's Game of
Life as comparable to the first cells
dividing in Earth's primordial oceans
the opening of a Pandora's Box that
marks a new chapter in the story of life
and what that chapter looks like will be
up to us
existential musings aside the future of
this sub-genre looks quite promising
there are plenty of other games that
feature evolution in some way that I
didn't get a chance to talk about if you
found this subject interesting once
again there are links to all the games
and scientific papers discussed in this
video down below with more information
about the incredible people who are
Paving the way in simulating evolution
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video